Se presenta 1 primavera
movidita y muy relevante políticamente.
Siempre se ha dicho que la duración de la legislatura
Nacional, la que mantiene a Pedro Sánchez en la Moncloa,
depende de cuándo se celebren
y cuál sea el resultado de las elecciones catalanas.
Pues bien, el Presidente de la generalidad, pero Aragonés,
acaba de anunciar
adelanto electoral y ha dicho que las elecciones
serán el próximo
12 de Mayo.
Esto es muy importante porque, en primer lugar,
en esta primavera VA a haber 3 citas electorales,
primero las vascas, que son en abril,
después las catalanas que son en Mayo
y luego las europeas,
que son en junio.
¿Cuál es la lectura Nacional
de todo este combo de elecciones?
Primero,
Esquerra adelanta las elecciones y coge a contrapié
al psc. Salvadorilla,
que estaba
en 1 estrategia de captar voto constitucionalista
y que estaba bastante disgustado
con la estrategia de Sánchez de aprobar 1 amnistía,
VA a IR a las elecciones
en plena negociación de la amnistía.
No VA a estar aprobada antes de las elecciones
porque por mucha prisa que se den,
no lo VA a estar antes del 12 de Mayo.
Por lo tanto, en pleno ruido político
sobre la negociación de la amnistía,
el psc se enfrenta a unas elecciones en Cataluña.
En segundo lugar,
coge a contrapié también al partido popular.
No tiene candidato en Cataluña,
no ha celebrado el congreso regional,
es el único que no ha celebrado de todos los de las
comunidades españolas y Tendrán que elegir
1 líder que represente
lo que Feijó quiere para Cataluña.
Este adelanto,
tercera lectura,
tiene mucho que ver con 1 decisión
que ha tomado en común podem,
la franquicia catalana de Yolanda Díaz.
Son ellos los que Han propiciado
que los presupuestos catalanes no se aprueben
y esto ha llevado al Presidente Aragonés a convocar
elecciones, a adelantar las elecciones.
Es decir, Yolanda Díaz le ha puesto 1 Palo en la rueda
a Pedro Sánchez.
Conclusión, se presenta 1 primavera movidita.
Es prematuro saber cómo estará el escenario político
Nacional después de las 3 citas electorales que hemos
señalado, pero lo cierto es que
ahí será el momento de hacer 1 balance
y de ver cuál es el efecto sobre las eh,
sobre la duración de la legislatura Nacional.
Primavera calentita y preocupación en Moncloa